okay so here we are eating your feet my
name is Nikki today my friend andrew has
challenged me to recreate a very
expensive beef sandwich that he tried
while he was in Japan shooting worth
everyone in this room has had the
sandwich except for me here's the video
this is at a restaurant in Tokyo called
Wagyu mafia cutlet sandwich so andrew
tried the Kobe beef
Chateaubriand penwick and Wow that piece
of meat is luxurious it's spotted like a
leopard with fat dredge it in an egg
wash and panco you just deep-fry it like
fried chicken and they have these
beautiful pieces of fluffy white bread
oh this is my kind of sandwich she cut
the crusts off 20,000 yen yeah we is
Kobe beef the same as Wagyu beef I
googled Kobe beef and the thing that is
up for sale is Wagyu beef Wagyu beef is
any of the four Japanese breeds of
cattle there's also one called send
abuse I thought it said Sandra beef and
I really liked the idea there being a
big old Sandra it's and uh I'll buy a
piece of beef and call it Sandra you
should also buy some less expensive meat
and plate this with that first maybe
some test beef yeah so as always to help
our very good friend and chef
extraordinaire Rhea is here are you I'm
making a Japanese sandwich today yeah I
remember this place is it good that's
good so wag you means Japanese beef
mm-hm and then this was a Kobe
Chateaubriand
is that a cut of beef yeah yes am I
gonna be able to find that here you may
able to not assume in a restaurant
saying like all the beef hmm and then is
that just like a regular katsu sauce we
can buy a sauce called punk rock salt
yes and then this bread I would like to
eat
we're just taking people's orders now
has a little bit lighter texture look
fluffier yeah fluffier and so the inside
is not cooked all the way through higher
comfort jar and shorter cook time
exactly good luck thanks bye so we need
to get cheap beef fancy beef tonkatsu
sauce bread crumbs white bread
preferably Japanese boyfriend I think I
can do this and I think it's gonna be a
really delicious day
[Music]
we got the beep it's not much the guy
who sold it to us said this is its
superior piece of meat
second only to Japanese Viking all right
we got stuff hey we got two square
loaves cheap beef expensive beef we have
our cuts of sauce and we've got some
panko in here we also have some treat
okay so we got this bread from a Korean
supermarket in Koreatown but they also
had a bakery so we got something hot dog
buns I got this pink baguette oh yeah I
do
super weird looks like you're eating
patrick stars a hand good luck thank you
I guess we get cooking so this process
requires deep frying things which
naturally makes me a little bit nervous
but I've got my pot of oil and we want
that too
oh I don't know anything about
temperature or time difference me me she
said high temperature before a short
amount of time well I mean it has to get
hot you're my thermometer I'm not like
tuned oh my god okay well safety first
that's heating up so from what I can
tell the beef is not like seasoned in
any way ingredients wise is pretty basic
so the fancy wag you that we got today
is not Kobe Wagyu but it's Australian
Wagyu from Blackmore farm and it is from
a Chateaubriand cut it is about an inch
and a half thick and it's $40 I think
this is like the smallest most expensive
piece of beef I've ever cooked we're not
gonna start with that because if I mess
it up we only have one so we bought some
backup beef Black Angus tenderloins but
they seem to be the right size this is
the Black Angus that is like seven
dollars per tenderloin and this is the
Chateaubriand Wagyu which is 40
something dollars this one definitely
has better marbling but like still not
quite like in the video in Japan but it
was the best we could do
right it goes flour and then eggs
I don't got two eggs but I think that
should be fine should I put salt in the
flour I don't remember if they salted it
I would definitely a salt the outside
after it's done frying well anything
stick
if it comes fresh out of the oil and it
just that's like that time to solve
right thing right oh that's a lot of
pink oh and also in the video they cook
with chopsticks that's what I'm gonna do
I'm about to deliver a beef baby the
thermometer says deep fry is near 375
which sounds about right here's our
Tenderloin fell into three pieces
because what did you give her Bain $15
for two tenderloins I had Wagyu beef for
the first time this summer at a fancy
Japanese restaurant and I cried all
right well I'm gonna dip this in egg
panko mountains yeah that's really a
well covered piece of beef Shendu this
little buddy
it looks like an apostrophe that can be
my test test piece singing Nikki's face
above the pot is very funny from over
here
all right we're there we're going in and
starting a timer this is fun just
sitting over here washing your back seat
on the front seat good okay that's one
minute it's so brown and crispy all
right 1:30 salt oh it's definitely rare
might be a little too rare it's hard to
tell though cuz this size of this guy
was also really small let's try the big
one see what we can do maybe we can make
a sandwich out of that one I remember
their beef taking kind of a while to
throw really maybe it's a lower temp and
a longer fry that's 2 minutes and 30
seconds all right let's test it with
like the end piece of this guy Wow such
a puffy bread
sauce on both pieces of bread or just
one maybe a light coating on both mmm so
and I think they cut the crust off after
the sandwich is assembled
nice and now I cut it into quarters
looks great looks pretty good pretty
close right yeah let's give it a go
[Music]
there's not a ton of beef flavors mostly
just like soft texture with crunchy
texture I think you can go a little less
two less fry mm-hmm guys is a little
overdone I would the floor may be a long
minute and a half when you take out the
meat it's still okay so I'll try it
again with my second piece of cheap meat
figure out a better cook time I'm hoping
this will just stay together when I fry
it we're gonna take it down to a minute
and a half hopefully get a little bit
more of a rare inside and assemble
another sandwich
cutting the bread at an angle here
because not a lot about me is very
straight so hopefully I can do a
straighter job well that's not a bad
slice okay minute thirty how the piece
didn't come off so Oh layer of sauce at
the Wagyu Sando place if there's a
little bit of meat that makes it not a
square it'll cut it a little bit so
that'll be more square like that looks a
lot better I think this cook time was
closer to what we should be doing okay I
think this is good you can see the
toasty bread the sauce the cups are
adding and my friend Sean's here hi Sean
come on
I made a cheap beef katsu Sando
but you were just in Japan I was just
yeah and you are Japanese yep so you
were familiar with the concept of the
cut suits and oh yes please enjoy pretty
good yeah although the beef is like not
super cooked which is good and we ate
the expensive one you just pull the meat
away from the sandwich then you have to
cut it with your teeth right cuz that
has to do the fat content mmm the
fattier it is the more it like breaks
apart more easily okay well there are no
more cheap steaks to futz with it's
finally time to face my fears of this
very expensive piece of beef I think I'm
going to slice my bread slices and have
them
ready to go in the toaster it's beef
time to up the stakes if you will injure
in Rae were gonna be here while I make
it calm in my palms are sweating you're
sweating I'm sweating here she is Angela
she's beautiful how perfectly round she
is should I dab I was talking about
dabbing the meat and Adam thought I was
gonna like dab dab like a 12 year old
boy it's got very nice marbling yeah
it's soft it's very tender can I do a
deal so h2 you what's an idiot okay here
she goes by Sandra me a timer yes Fred's
toasting I'm very nervous it's been a
minute
already oh nice color
oh that piece about funky that's okay go
cut that off
you're like a coach it's time for Sandra
she's big oh wow that's thick mom and
dad behind me you can do it okay ready
Oh
it's basically just toasted meat right
this is really really ridiculous okay
let's make a Wagyu beef I cry
I really don't know what's gonna happen
here oh the juices are running that's so
decadent well they taste like
marshmallow like a beef mallow mmm this
one has a beefiness that the other two
didn't have feel like the fat has a
flavor of its own and this one that is
present in the others this one the beef
is the star I feel like in the other
pieces we were talking about the Breton
sauce olive oil mm-hmm this one like the
beef just really really stands out yeah
that's crazy that's good Thank You Annie
I heard you were excited to try some
beef I was you're not in the rare beef
no I'll try anything
you felt like we all ate it and it was
just bad rare food really really good
yeah someone's life today
we had a very expensive piece of Wagyu
Chateaubriand that was dredged in flour
eggs and panko and then deep-fried until
it was rare and then we had some soft
fluffy Japanese white bread covered in a
katsu sauce with the meat placed on it
cut into quarters I can't even imagine
what that restaurant is doing with like
high tier Japanese Kobe Wagyu beef but I
think with whatever a piece of beef you
can find if you want to do this at home
you totally can
I'd say definitely spring for the good
Asian bread get a good sauce any
delicious sandwich Wow
I just smell like beef
oh yes